star wars the bad
batch i thought these guys were so cool
in the finale of the clone wars freaking
awesome if you guys didn't see my
my uh series finale reaction to the
clone wars it is up on youtube now let's
not talk anymore let's watch this damn
trailer
they call themselves
[Music]
ricks
damn polished
[Applause]
empire they really aren't affected by
order 66
okay just curious about that
oh
[Applause]
dude it's quite an impressive
taking on the whole war themselves
badass with a bad batch i heard about
this show being announced before i even
got to them
in the clone wars series when i was
watching this show i was
i had the mindset of are these gonna be
the kind of guys i would want to see a
series based on
immediately from their first episode
which i i believe they were kind of like
the first or really early on in the
beginning part of
the final season of the clone wars damn
yeah the these guys are
just super badass there's like the
clones and then there's the bad batch
who play by their own rules but they
still fight the good fight but they're
like
rough as nails and they got echo now on
the team which i'm very much excited
about i love the way that concluded and
here you do get some images there's one
spot here
where it looked like it could have been
the helmet similar to fenix shams but i
don't think that's fenix shane that
wouldn't make sense she's timeless
they have to be a kid at this point at
one point that looks like the sarlacc
they are following the season seven
animation style left off from the clone
wars and how beautiful
that looked and i feel like with how
epic and intense and dark
those final four episodes of the clone
wars was this alone
will probably follow in that same type
of tone and mood because while there's
humor to be had they're not anti-heroes
but they got they have like the
personality in them but they're heroes
all right they're just rough here yeah
exactly i'm excited to see if they'll
follow more in that kind of tone
spiritually
where it is just fighting the galactic
empire
in the mid right after order 66 and see
if they can even try to get through
through some of the clones some of their
brothers obviously i don't i don't have
quite as much of a familiarity with the
breadth of the clone wars story just yet
as you do but this definitely suckered
me in as more of an
outsider i mean i love the way the
animation has grown because you know
from seeing earlier episodes
knowing some of the clips that have come
out from the final season like i've
always been excited to see that grow
because when i first saw like clone wars
drop back in the day i was like i don't
know if the animation's gonna be a block
for me
this looks really cool and it looks
really action-packed and at least again
from what i know about clone wars this
looks like it's taking it into a more
sort of i don't know military ensemble
direction of sort
i want to see it at the beginning of
order 66. the way how the final season
of clone wars
had you as focus on ahsoka tano's
perspective when order 66 start
happening i'd like the series to pick up
there to see how they deal with the
handling of the information
and like what the hell is going on right
now i mean as long as we're going back
through you know the established
timeline might as well see
one of the most significant events on it
from
multiple sides because as the star wars
universe has proven it's a huge
ecosystem and everything affects
everyone all right guys well star wars
the bad batch are you excited for this
series leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button if you enjoyed our
vid we'll catch you guys soon